this one says how does dolly parton play
the guitar with those nails
pretty dang good
hey gq this is dolly and i'm
going undercover on the internet this
is actually me
first up twitter jordan
i just read that dolly parton that's me
wrote jolene and i will always love you
on the same day is there any truth in
that well i'm not
certain but i'll tell you this we found
an old cassette when we were getting
through all my songs going down in my
basement and all those old cassettes
where i had written songs
and jolene and i will always love you
was on the same cassette
so if i didn't write it on the same day
it was during that same week or that
period of time while i still had that
particular cassette in my little player
at the time so
it's very possible that it happened
because i know they're both on the same
album
the jolene album posted nine to five
has always been a favorite dolly song of
mine what was the first job she ever had
prior to being a country music icon
i soar or icon that's from abby
actually my first job was writing songs
i think i used to sing on a local radio
show back in knoxville tennessee when i
was 10 years old and my uncle bill owens
used to take me around to sing
and all the local shows so i would say
my first job
besides working in the fields and
working at home was singing
posted okay samantha says
i wonder if dolly parton is proud of
miley
well of course dolly parton's proud of
miley she's my goddaughter i've known
her since she's a teeny weeny baby even
before she was born
i used to pat her mama's belly and billy
ray who was a friend of mine her daddy
said you got to be her godmother i said
well i would love to be we've had a
wonderful relationship
i feel like the cyrus family is like my
second family i love molly love billy
love all of them
you may not believe it but it's actually
me
okay instagram
so this one says dolly do you do your
own hair
it always looks so nice well thank you
somebody says how long does it take to
do your hair i don't know i'm never
there
you know i wear wigs a lot and of course
it doesn't take me long to do my real
hair because i'm so used to doing it i
appreciate that
and it is nice to have wigs because i
never really have a bad hair day
okay wikipedia
i met johnny cash when i was 13 years
old at the grand old opry
yes that is true johnny cash introduced
me on the grand ole opry we became good
friends through the years he and june
as well but i don't remember him
encouraging me
to follow my dreams or anything i just
remembered i was very
encouraged by him that i got to meet him
because i thought he was so
handsome so sexy that's the first time i
really felt like a woman when i was
around him he kind of stirred all that
stuff in me and we've
always laughed about that i told june
i've had a crush on him all my life
my husband carl dean and i did renew our
vows when we had been married 50 years
because we didn't get a chance to have
that big old wedding that we wanted to i
wanted that beautiful gown
and all that well i had the money to do
it this time
so we just kind of went all out but we
did do it at home close quarters and all
but we did get to wear that beautiful
gown and he got to dress up in his
beautiful suit we made beautiful
pictures
and he bought me another wedding ring i
still have my originals wouldn't take
nothing for those but yeah that's true
that was four years ago
more twitter seriously it's actually me
this one says how does dolly parton play
the guitar with those nails
pretty dang good
posted who inspired you to become a
singer well
i was inspired just by living and
living in a household where everybody
was a singer played musical instruments
my mom's people were all
very musical so all my brothers and
sisters could play
some musical instruments sing we all did
so i learned to
sing and i was impressed most by my
aunts and uncles and my mom
and all the people that were around me
that did sing and we grew up in the
church
and that really inspired me as well all
that beautiful singing my grandpa was a
preacher and also
a good singer also play piano and guitar
this one says isn't it insane that dolly
parton has her
own theme park yes it's insane
and it's wonderful it was a dream of
mine since i was
early on in my career i thought if i
make it big i'm gonna go back home
and open up a theme park and now we have
dollywood and we're so proud of that and
thanks to all of you out there that come
to see us
and thank you for saying it's a
wonderful thing it is insane
but a good kind of crazy this one asked
if it's true that
katy perry asked me to be on the stage
with her at the super bowl
and that is true and i would have done
it because i love katy perry but at the
time my husband was not doing good he
was kind of puny and i couldn't leave
him so i couldn't do it but one of these
days
maybe we'll do it again i love her
did she ever have her baby okay reddit
why does jolene by dolly parton sound so
different
from the rest of the album well i don't
know
i wrote most of the songs on it but
jolene just was one of those funky
little tunes kind of in a minor
key and it just is different i think a
lot of it because of that
it's just its own little personality
it's been recorded more times than any
song that i've ever written
it was supposed to be different i'm
different
you're different posted thank you for
the questions
i'm signing off the internet see you
next time